you're a feminist and you don't like
what I'm saying you want to come on and
have this debate with me let's do it
let's do it because I am debating this
Co from from a position of fact and what
we know and information we have and the
fact that it's very obvious to me very
obviously there was a campaign to shut
down a guy that a lot of people felt his
message was destructive
and I did all research I looked at it so
I laid it out here because you know why
people say why do you do this on Twitter
Jed I do it because you've got to like
stop this nonsense you gotta gut out the
cancer of actual misinformation before
you get labeled misinformation even
though you're telling the truth and
suddenly you're banned you can't you
gotta cut the cancer out and the cancer
is this willingness of people who are
very fragile
to label people your bigot you're a
misogynist rapist racist raping they
don't know what word to say with no
justification because essentially what
it is is they're uncomfortable with his
commentary they don't like it and
they're like shaken because they don't
know what to do about it